DAVID SEIDMAN: Hi, everyone.
My name is David Seidman.
I'm a product manager
in Google Cloud.
And today we'll be
doing a deep dive
on data protection
capabilities in compute engine
and persistent disk.
So what we'll be covering today
will be a general overview
of this area.
And then some depth on what we
do around backup and disaster
recovery.
A new capability
we're introducing
called disk cloning.
Capabilities for
high availability.
Workload consistency.
And then a set of best
practices that you
can apply to your workloads.
So this is a 300 level session.
There'll be some technical
depth on some existing features.
Some new features that
we are announcing.
And again, in the context
of best practices,
how to choose the
right tool for the job
so that particular feature or
particular even feature flag
is the right choice for
whatever your scenario is.
So in terms of our
mission and who we serve,
our goal is to serve the
most demanding workloads.
So workloads with demanding
recovery point objectives,
recovery time objectives,
workloads that demand
flexibility, whether it's around
cost, or data sovereignty,
or performance.
And the capabilities that
we'll be talking about today
are a foundation for
critical services,
both inside of Google,
and also across
many different industries.
You can see here some examples.
Energy, retail, media, finance.
The list goes on.
So this is a foundation
that we bet on,
and then also
customers use across
many different industries.
So as a high-level overview,
starting with scenarios.
Kind of think about the world
in terms of some major functions
or scenarios.
For backup and for
disaster recovery,
we have a highly reliable
high-performance snapshots.
And we'll be talking
more about those.
If the goal is flexibility
for data mobility, copy data
management, we'll talk a lot
about what we mean by that.
But for example, very quickly
getting data from production
to staging.
Or very quickly moving
data from a production
workload to kind of
a scratch environment
where you can do
auditing or verification.
Disk clones are the
recommended feature for that.
For high availability,
we have a product
that's been GA since
early 2019 called
regional persistent disks.
We'll talk a lot about
how we think about HA.
And then for
application consistency,
we have two new features.
Google Machine Images and
guest-flush. guest-flush
is actually an existing feature.
But we've made some
enhancements to it
that we'll be we'll
be talking about.
OK.
So some more depth on snapshots.
So snapshots provide
resilient backup
for failures that could
be within the region
or within the service.
So what we mean
by that is, if you
have persistent disk
running in a certain region,
a snapshot allows you
to extract that data,
and the snapshot is
created in another region.
And it happens to be stored
actually in different service
from persistent
disk, stored in GCS.
So that means even if there's
a failure, or some sort
of outage, or accidental
issue with your desk,
or with that region,
or even with PD
overall, the data
is highly protected.
And there's a lot
of options here.
So for example, by being able
to put a snapshot in any region
or multi-region, you
can optimize for cost.
You can optimize for resilience.
For example, putting your
data on a different continent.
You can optimize for performance
by keeping your snapshot close
to the disk in the
same region, optimizing
for how long it takes
to create and restore
that snapshot, or
data sovereignty.
So if you need to keep
your data in Montreal
or in a certain
jurisdiction in Europe,
you can choose
exactly which location
the snapshot is stored in.
I talked a little about
some of the agility.
If you have a disk, and you
wish to take a snapshot of it,
that snapshot will go to
any region or multi-region
you select.
And if you have a snapshot
in a region or multi-region,
and you wish to
restore it to a disk,
that can directly be used to
create a disk in any region.
In terms of thinking
about performance
for these workflows,
it's important to know
that once you create a
disk from a snapshot,
those disks will run at full
performance, full speed,
as soon as the snapshot
restore completes.
So whatever I/O,
throughput, latency
that you need for
your critical loads
will be there once the disk
is available and attached.
So you don't need
to worry about,
for example, having an
attached disk, which
sometimes is performing,
and sometimes may not
be performing well.
And in general, as
a basic principle,
the more data that you're moving
to create or restore snapshots,
the longer it will take.
If you have a very
large disk that you're
taking a snapshot of
for the first time
or that you're
restoring, that will
take longer than an
incremental snapshot
that you're capturing more
frequently with just small data
changes.
So let's talk a little
about consistency.
So a new area here that
we'll be talking about,
something that's coming
soon, and something that's
now in beta, we want to
ensure that in addition
to the crash consistency
that snapshots provide,
if you need some additional
level of consistency,
either across disks
or up to the level
of the guest for your
application workload,
there's options for that.
So the guest-flush flag has
been available for a long time
for snapshots but
for Windows only,
integrating with Windows VSS.
What we're introducing
coming soon
is support for this flag on
Linux and the way it works
is it integrates
with script hooks.
So within the guest that has
the disk attached that you're
snapshotting, you
can create or place
a script that executes
before the snapshot is taken
and after the snapshot is taken.
So that can provide a lot of
flexibility, a lot of control
inside the guest.
So for example, you can
quiesce an application
before the snapshot is taken.
And then you can un-quiesce it
after the snapshot is taken.
You can trigger automation.
You can run scripting to figure
out what kind of applications
are running on the guest so
that you have visibility for,
let's say, any cataloging
or additional verification
you want to do for
those workloads.
Exactly what those scripts
do and how this flag works
for those script hooks on
Linux depends on the behavior
of the script themselves.
So the consistency
or other behavior
is entirely up to those scripts.
And this can be provided
either by something
that you roll your
own, or you can
work with your favorite backup
or disaster recovery provider
that we partner with
for those scripts.
Another feature in
the same category
is Google Machine Image.
This is now in beta.
So this is available
for anyone to use.
Google Machine Image,
sometimes called GMIs,
provide a point-in-time
image of a full instance.
So that means VM configuration
and data from multiple disks.
So if you're running
a workload on a VM,
and the data on multiple disks
that are attached has some sort
of dependency on one another--
let's say data as well
as the transaction logs for
that data that should be kept
in sync--
when the Google Machine
Image is captured,
it's captured consistently
and anatomically.
So this is great for
instance replication,
backup, restore, or even putting
a GMI into the marketplace.
Again, it captures the disk
data as well as the metadata
consistently.
And you can use
this in conjunction
with guest-flush so
that you get consistency
both across the disks on a VM
as well as up into the workload.
Let's talk about a new feature
that we touched on a little
in the introduction.
We are now providing
a capability
we call disk cloning.
So the reason that we've
introduced this capability
is there's often scenarios where
you may have data on a disk--
let's say a running
disk in production--
and you very quickly want to
create a new disk from the data
on that source disk.
So today, there's a few
ways you can create disks.
You can create a blank disk.
You can create a
disk from an image.
disk from a snapshot.
This provides an additional way.
So for example, if
before you had a disk,
and you just wanted to create
another disk in the same zone,
you would have to
create a snapshot
and then restore
the snapshot down.
So you're moving data
basically up and down
through just a
temporary place holder
snapshot where you may
not in practice actually
need that snapshot to be
to be a durable backup.
So just moving that data could
be very slow if you're moving,
let's say, tens of
terabytes of data.
That could take
a very long time.
Disk clones are
optimized for performance
and for this exact scenario
where, again, what you
want is a disk,
and in particular,
a disk in that same
local zone where
you're running that workload.
And you can expect this
to typically complete
in a minute or less.
So we talked about scenarios of
quickly bringing up a staging
environment from production.
If you are running a
workload or a database
and want to run some
kind of verification
or do some sort
of export of data,
rather than running
that export and sort
of walking the disk
while it's still attached
and supporting your
production workload,
you can now clone it,
attach it to a second VM,
and then do whatever
verification, or processing,
or exporting you want on a
completely separate cloned
system.
For these scenarios, this
is also a cost saving.
So if the goal was to
create a second disk anyway,
now you're saving
money on the snapshots
that are no longer needed.
The cloned disks are in
many ways ordinary disk.
So they're live, attachable,
fully provisioned,
writable disks.
They run at full speed.
There are some constraints.
So I mentioned disk clone must
be in the same local zone.
And it also needs to
be of the same type.
So the same disks used.
So if you have an SSD
disk, you can clone it
into an SSD disk,
not an HDD disk.
And this is also designed
for high frequency.
So you can clone a
disk every 30 seconds.
And again, you can expect
the actual cloning process
to be high performance.
This is just a visual
of one of those flows.
So again, if you're taking
those one-off snapshots
today for a high value disk
just to create additional disks,
again, for dev
test, export, audit,
now those one-off snapshots
are not necessary.
And another scenario--
If you are, let's say,
scheduling downtime
for a workload in
order to do an upgrade,
now you can have
much more protection
with higher performance.
So the scenario here would be--
take a clone of a disk,
save it as a rollback point.
So if you're worried
about the upgrade,
let's say, being unsuccessful
or corrupting the application
in some way, and you really want
that safe intact rollback point
of before you tried to
change your application,
you would clone it,
stop the workload,
do whatever upgrade
is needed, verify,
and if the upgrade succeeds,
you can discard that clone.
You don't need it anymore.
But if it fails and you want
to get your upgrade running
and you want to get your
application running again
as soon as possible,
just swap in clone disk
and restart your
workload, and you're back
to that healthy state.
So again, this optimizes
this flow where otherwise you
would need to copy the data
up and down to a snapshot
to get back to that
saved pre-upgrade state.
OK.
So let's switch to
high availability.
So regional persistent
disk is our offering here.
It provides some basics on
what it is and how it works.
And then we'll talk
about how it supports
different kinds of
failure scenarios
to provide high availability.
So regional persistent
disk provides
synchronous replication between
two zones in the same region.
So what that means is that as a
workload is writing to a disk,
there's a second replica of
that disk in another zone.
And we ensure that that data
is committed on both sides.
So what that means is that if
you have a single failure--
let's say you have a network
disconnect or a sustained
outage in zone--
your recovery point objective
can be met at 0 data loss.
Versus, let's say,
using snapshots
where you may take
a snapshot, then
if your workload is destroyed
or has some sort of outage,
you can always
restore your snapshot.
But the amount of
data loss that you
would have with the
snapshot scenario
would be the amount
of time that elapsed
between when you
took the snapshot
and when the outage occurred.
Here, using regional persistent
disk, your RPO is zero.
This is designed for
maximum availability.
So what that means is, let's say
that your failover zone becomes
unavailable.
We still maintain
the availability
of the workload in
that primary zone.
So we favor maximum
availability,
which also means that if you
have an outage in one zone,
let's say in your failover
zone, your data is
still running and intact with no
data loss in your primary zone,
you want to take
some mitigations.
We keep your workload running
even when one of those zones
goes down.
The other thing I
want to emphasize
is this offering provides
additional replication
between two zones.
But every zonal persistent
disks meet or exceed
three copies within each zone
for additional durability.
So just a little more detail
on the failure management
that I was outlining.
So you can imagine
two scenarios.
One is if you have a failure
in your primary HA zone,
we recommend using health
checks to determine if back-ends
are responding to traffic.
So that's the way you would
detect if there's a failure.
If there's a failure
in your primary zone,
and you want a failover
in the secondary zone,
the recovery time
needed to attach
that disk to a failover VM will
typically be a minute or less.
So again, the data is replicated
to the secondary zone.
And you'll be attaching
a VM to that disk.
It's actually one
logical disk that's
represented in those two zones.
The actual RTO that
you achieve will depend
on how you manage your VM.
So for example, if you have
a hot standby VM that's
running all the time versus
a VM that you need to start,
that, of course, will affect
your recovery time objective.
In the scenario where a failure
occurs in the secondary HA
zone, if you're thinking about
a primary secondary pair,
then again, the data that
you're continuing to maintain
and your available
primary zone is there.
But you've lost
your HA protection
because your secondary
zone is now down.
So in that case,
the best practice,
and in fact, we would always
recommend this best practice,
is to use scheduled snapshots.
So scheduled
snapshots can ensure
that you're at least bounding
your recovery point objective,
even if you have that secondary
zone become unavailable
so that if there is
then a second failure--
let's say there's a regional
outage or some other sort
of loss--
you now have snapshots as an
additional layer of protection.
The other thing that's
important to know
about regional persistent
disk is catch up
and failure recovery
is automatic.
So let's say there's a
network outage in replicating
to a second zone.
Once that's resolved,
the replicas
will automatically be caught
up and brought in sync.
OK.
So let's talk about some best
practices for these features.
So the first point we made
in the context of clones.
Avoid temporary snapshots
whenever possible.
So again, we know
that for scenarios
where the goal is to create
a new disk immediately
for the scenarios that
we have described,
copying back and forth to a
snapshot is a waste of time,
and also a waste of resources,
and an unnecessary cost.
So you can use clones for
much higher performance
and cost saving benefits.
The second best practice is if
you want to very quickly create
new disks, especially
across region,
images are the best
resource for that.
So again, if you have
a single data source,
and you want to very quickly
create large numbers of disks,
including between
regions, images
are optimized for that scenario.
So there's local
caching that we do
in persistent disk
in any target zone
that you're starting
to create new disks,
and you'll see much faster
high performance disk creation.
The third best practice
that we talked about
in the context of
regional persistent disk,
but applies really
everywhere, is
to schedule hourly snapshots for
backup and disaster recovery.
So we have a built-in
scheduled snapshots capability.
This is a great way to
limit any risk of data loss.
If there is, again, some outage,
or disaster, or human error.
The other thing to
consider is some customers
like to take daily
snapshots, which is great.
If that frequency can be
increased so that snapshots
are taken every 6, hours or
12 hours, or something daily,
that will lead to
smaller uploads
rather than uploading all of
the changes for the last day.
And that will support faster
snapshot creation times.
OK.
So hopefully this will be
useful as sort of a reference
chart in thinking about
scenarios, features,
and what they're
purpose-built for.
So again, snapshots
we really think
of as optimized for
long-term data backup.
You can find pricing
information on our website.
And, again, information
about exactly how
we manage full
snapshots and then
incremental changes of
those snapshots as you
take more snapshots
from the same disk.
And again, if what you need
is geo-redundancy or long-term
backup, it's the best option.
If the goal is
high availability,
regional persistent disk
is purpose-built for that.
It's not built for backup.
So if a region is somehow
completely unavailable
or destroyed in
some way, you would
need snapshots in
addition to regional PD
to have that durable
geo-redundant backup.
But regional persistent
disk gives you
that zero RPO for a single
failure and that very low RTO.
Disk clones also not intended
for disaster recovery.
Those are optimized
for efficiently
creating new disks in the
same zone from a production
workload.
So again, we talked about the
examples of export offloading,
forking data into staging
very frequently optimized
for that purpose.
And then as we look
at Google Machine
Images and the
guest-flush option,
those are optimized
for consistency.
So whether you need consistency
across multiple disks that
are working together to
support a workload on one VM,
or whether or not
you want consistency
up into the guest itself, again,
for application quiescence,
or verification, or additional
information and control that's
only available
inside of the guest.
And looking at it from
the scenario perspective,
just to recap--
backup and DR, we
recommend using snapshots.
For efficiently moving
data within a zone
to bring up new workloads,
we recommend disk clones.
And then for high availability,
regional persistent disks.
And then we have
these two options
depending on the nature of
the application consistency
that you need.
So thank you very much.
And we look forward to
hearing your feedback.